you might not know but Josh is a bit of
a chef especially when it comes to
dining on a budget he's back to a couple
of recipes that he perfected during his
early days of doing stand-up so this is
when you were poor garbage poor people
food that you're gonna make for us I've
never done a cooking segment before
everybody so excited so this is white
rice right okay I've never watched
somebody
white rice right and like white rice you
can get super cheap canned tuna I know
it sounds gross as can be I don't like
it you don't like it I'm just gonna put
a little bit in there for you Doug I
can't do it I'm not gonna do the whole
thing yeah go a line of the tuna now the
sesame oil is the kitty kitty kitty
because the sesame oil kills the exact
taste you're not gonna like it kills it
and then
this is my favorite hot sauce Crystal
hot sauce okay
how'd you do it's exactly how I remember
[Laughter]
I think that's gonna be better now I
remember why I added so many different
sauces to it because the rice and tuna
together
[Laughter]
maybe it just tasted good because it was
the only food I could afford to eat
foreign
[Music]
that's how big her titties were they
made that noise through the air
[Music]